cryptocurrency what's uh well what's a
cryptocurrency you uh
what what crypt we gotta be careful
we're not giving anything we're not
giving anybody advice
you're wrong chain link no keep trying
dogecoin yes yes let's go deep on the
doors
we got the story from cnet dogecoin
inside the joke cryptocurrency that
somehow became real love it how dogecoin
became
one of the world's most valuable
cryptocurrencies
wow such return june 22nd
2014 jackson palmer a self-identified
average
geek in is high in the stands at nascar
race in sonoma
raceway california he's an australian
man in his 20s he has zero interest in
racing
never in his wildest dreams did he
imagine it would become it would come to
this
he surveys the scene below a trend a
tremendous crowd okay blah blah blah
emblazoned on the top the word dogecoin
in all caps below digital currency
palmer describes situation using words
like crazy surreal and nuts
he remembers this moment as a reality
check dogecoin was a tweet
then it was a cryptocurrency worth money
in the real world
six months later he watched as a joke
that he'd made in passing
somehow manifested itself into something
tangible
a doge car in full flight what it
reminded palmer how insane the world
could be
this is the story of dogecoin the joke
that became too real for its own good
look at this
the doge car and it all is a real thing
doge
coin digital currency ford this is
amazing stuff
at one point dogecoin was worth two
billion dollars
it's difficult to make sense of that
dogecoin is an easily replic
replicable coin i don't know how it
distinguishes itself
from bitcoin i really think it has to do
with it being established early
and also the dog ladies and gentlemen
this garbage joke me okay i shouldn't
call it garbage okay this is just a
pretty profitable
joke yeah i'm fairly confident
that i have probably a hundred or more
thousand
dogecoin maybe even hundreds probably
sitting on a computer in a warehouse
somewhere
in a garage buried in a button you know
and just totally gone and ignored and
boy
do i regret it now wait where is this
it's in a storage unit probably in
someone's garage somewhere in chicago
maybe i have no idea
no in chicago really that's close by
where i live i remember a couple years
ago a friend coming to me being like buy
some deutsch i'm like why he's like it's
pointless i'm like okay
and i bought some deutsch so that's
that's what a lot of people are doing
they're like it's absolutely pointless
but now it's
it's some reports are coming in five
cents
deutsch i mean that's doge that that
that that's crazy
okay listen listen dogecoin was a joke
cryptocurrency yeah bitcoin is open
source so someone cloned it and said
dogecoin we got it now you can get it
and so uh i did you know why because it
was worthless
it was completely worthless the amount
of value it had
i could probably pick a rock up off the
ground and trade it for 50
000 dogecoin like that well maybe not a
rock off the ground but you'd still get
some
yeah it was worth like three billionths
of a cent or something stupid
and so it's three cents i mean it's it's
you would be
a millionaire i gotta find my old
computer i can't find it a thousand
bucks in the dogecoin back if you
if you had if you at the time if you
just collected a couple hundred thousand
you'd have what would you have thousands
of dollars right now now that's at five
cents
i have two thousand dogecoin you do yeah
have you always sat on it for like two
two and a half years because it's
hilarious
i'm considering buying a bunch more i
don't know i mean it's so volatile it's
tough to say like the internet wants to
make
chain link go viral but the thing is
it's dogecoin elon musk finds it funny
so he's going to tweet about it from
time to time
and in moments of hot hate on the us
dollar people are gonna swing it
so maybe it's it's wise to it's
beautiful to load twenty percent of mine
it's beautiful to watch well elon just
tweeted the dollar is shortening itself
and obviously he tweets a lot about
deutsch but again what i've been saying
what i've been personally doing
is i never invest what i'm not willing
to lose that's
me personally myself not financial
advice don't listen to me or just
uh like podcasters just people on the
internet
that uh make stupid decisions like buy
deutsche coin a few years ago and then
they they can't find their laptops
right so it happens this makes me wonder
if like anything could be a
cryptocurrency
if you can literally turn a little dog
meme into a currency that's it's just
vanity
it's just branding right yeah and then
you gotta re certain ones you have to
register with the sec
if you want to make them securities that
you can buy and sell um otherwise you
can make a utility token which you can't
buy and sell legally with you don't have
to register with the sec and those are
much easier
to create but if you really i think doge
is a security
so they went the distance with that one
well today i learned
dogecoin surges 77
as retail fever pitch stretches into
crypto
wow i have a i have a horrifying
prospect for you
what happens if dogecoin displaces
bitcoin well dogecoin is
i'm now up 390 in the last 24 hours
why if it surpasses bitcoin i think we
will truly
we got a long way to go there we have a
long way to go it's it's it's currently
at like what you say five cents
yeah i'm ready to uh bitcoins thirty
thousand dollars you never know what
hyperinflation though
you know well here's what happens too
many powerful special interests are
buying into bitcoin
so what happens now when people are like
i'd rather just hold dogecoin
right there are also 128 billion
dogecoin to be printed whereas there's
only 12
billion 12 18 million
bitcoin so you're looking at like a
difference just out of the
off the bat of like a thousand times a
thousand you're never going to have
dogecoin be worth more than like a
thousandth of a bitcoin if dogecoin ever
hits a dollar
i'm going to go try and find that
they're saying it's a dollar in 2021
just send me to try to find it i swear
i'll bring it back where's that computer
where did i put it tim i'll go get it
it's a long time ago i'll bring it back
i swear
yeah yeah you have to have the physical
wallets you have to download you tip
the blockchain that's right um they're
trying to remember where it is they're
calling it meme coins
i think that's the new the new coins
think about this right
so the one benefit of cryptocurrency
is that you can freely trade so uh
if you're banned from banking if you
can't make a transaction for whatever
reason if you you don't have
you know if there's some kind of block
in your way they can't delist it
like they did right stocks i can well so
more importantly an easy way to transfer
value to
someone anywhere in the world would be
buy some dosh
and then trade the doge to ian and then
ian sells the dosh for cash and
wherever he is and that value instantly
transmits you know it's very very
quickly
so if there's some kind of block in the
way that's stopping us from making that
transaction
dogecoin is a mean to transmit value to
someone else
it doesn't matter what crypto it is as
long as it has value and you can trade
it rapidly
then the value goes in and out and it's
almost like converting the money into a
signal and then converting it back
so dogecoin has that value but that's
kind of it
i mean you you could it's it's built off
of bitcoin
you could theoretically do smart
contracts i guess not like ethereum
right i don't know the the depths of of
the
doge um i want to relay some problems
the depths of the dogs will go there um
with coinbase
i made a purchase on coinbase they
double charged my bank account
oh they wouldn't get back to me because
they're overloaded with um i've
been kinda with them for two weeks so i
contacted my bank and i was like i'm
gonna need to stop payment on this
double charge they stopped the payment
coinbase then
took the cryptocurrency out of my
account claiming that i still owed them
for this this stopped payment now and
basically take took half my money so i
it's not i don't i don't like coins this
was good i told you what are you doing
it was the only option the first thing
you told me i was like i'm using coins
i'm like what are you doing
like i had to give i gave you i gave you
another wallet i was like you should use
this one coinbase
if you're listening or watching the show
get your act together yeah man
i filed a complaint with them and i'm
still waiting it's what is so obnoxious
they're the worst
what if there's some kind of correlation
between dogecoin and like the book of
revelations
and dogecoin is a sign of the end times
the mark of the beast
no i'm kidding the doge i'm just
thinking about so i don't know if you
guys heard that the the
the scientists or whatever said the the
doomsday clock is now 100 seconds to
midnight
wait what can say that all over again i
think i missed everything
there are these scientists who have a
thing called the doomsday clock yes
you're familiar with it
vaguely once the doomsday clock is a
metaphorical clock reaches midnight
the apocalypse is here yes it's at 100
seconds to midnight
that's what they're saying when right
now right now okay look 100 seconds is a
reference to how close we are to
collapse it doesn't mean a literal
hundred seconds
okay because so the point i'm bringing
single out here so i don't want to die
you know this is doomsday look
somebody's marrying right
this is yeah relative to like the
creation of humanity like 20
000 years ago or is this to the creation
of this the solar system like this this
hundreds
of clouds what is it based on it just
literally means that when they move the
clock closer to midnight we're closer to
annihilation
that's it well apocalypse the apocalypse
that we called it like doomsday it's not
actually the end of the world it's just
like a great reckoning
of us the nuclear biblical apocalypse i
don't think it is it's the end of
everything
no you know who enough guys i'm talking
about the doomsday clock
it's a group of people who have created
a symbol
for how they represent how close we get
to destroying ourselves
for a long period it was five minutes to
midnight and this is a reference to the
cold war and nuclear war
and they've kept moving it up because of
climate change and now it's sitting at
100 seconds it's just a symbol
where they're saying we're closer than
ever to killing ourselves
i bring it up because looking at
dogecoin skyrocketing but more
importantly looking at the sheer
market manipulation that people have
figured out how to do and the markets
are now responding with
everyone's realizing there's nothing
real anymore
the no one no one believes the same set
of facts money is basically meaningless
at this point because people are
randomly becoming millionaires off of
going on the internet and just buying
some random stock someone told them to
buy
actually now dogecoin's going through i
think we're in a very good place with
humanity i've been thinking a lot about
the ice age and people like global
warming but
as our our ice caps melted 12 800 years
ago with a commentary impact i think
we're still in an ice age
and we're just coming out of the last
ice age now naturally
and we're about to develop fusion power
so i think we're okay
i think i think we're going places i'm
talking about like the u.s current
global economic order that's going to
shatter that's that's a weird it's
falling apart like a snake in the grass
get into the do whatever but that's what
i was saying about
the the the game stop rebellion being
just the beginning
i mean these people have figured out how
to do it why are they going to stop so
you better i'm saying
you banned gamestop okay well let's uh
what do we have next coles
sears the sears have stock because
they're they're they're flopping around
right their stores are shuttering yeah
they own a lot of real estate though
that's that's what they do they have
those big buildings yes they do
so so what what are they going to be
like oh no you banned our stocks hey
guys we're going to buy this one now and
then they're going to ban that
what do you think happens then when one
day they ban literally every stock and
there's no stock market anymore good
yeah but we're also heading towards the
retail collapse and also with
automation and technological
advancements we are going to see a
huge displacement of individuals being
able to actually have a job
being actually able to earn for
themselves and i think this is another
reason why this
happened people are realizing hey we
can't have a small business we can't
operate at all let's try to make some
money
online hey we collectively we could be
our own hedge fund
let's let's have the people's heads
funds and then what do they do they get
smacked down by the establishment
by the government by the mainstream
media i mean i'm reading some of these
articles they're mind-blowing forbes
wrote an article titled ignore the
populist
game stop hype short sellers are heroes
are you kidding me like how more
insane and crazy can you get to
to try to justify this to use such spin
such
propaganda to try to somehow manipulate
people to
think that people coming together and
playing the stock market just like the
hedge funds are
is is something bad i mean they allowed
small businesses to be destroyed and
people haven't forgotten that
but but they're protecting hedge funds
now no no that doesn't add up to
anyone's
calculations that doesn't make sense to
anyone who
actually is playing by the rules who's
paying their taxes who's doing
everything that they were told to do
and they're still getting screwed over
at the end of the day that energy
that feeling that contemptness that is
brewing
that is here and that's going to erupt
soon under abide in presidency and
that's for weeks i mean you were we were
here on the show i was telling you weeks
occupy wall street's coming there's
going to be a new wave i don't know
exactly how it's going to
magnify but the feeling the energy that
was before
occupy wall street before the two you
know after the 2008 housing market crash
it's the same energy now but eight times
10 and more anxious and more hyperbolic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you